Speaker 1: OK, let's jump in to audience questions
for the week, first question about guns.
David, why have mass shootings skyrocketed
in the United States?
It is true that mass shootings have increased
in the United States.
There is unlikely to be a significant agreement
on this issue politically right now.
But to me, it seems very clear that there
are at least a few factors that together have
led the United States to be in the situation
that it's in now for the people that focus
only on guns.
I actually don't think guns are the problem.
They are a major problem in the United States.
The easy availability of firearms, combined
with the lack of a universal background check
program, the lack of an insurance requirement,
the ease with which you can purchase large
capacity magazines, I mean, there's a lot
that relates to guns, but.
There are countries like Switzerland, and
I know it's almost cliche to even bring it
up at this point in time, there are countries
with high rates of gun ownership that do not
have our gun violence problem, and that is
because of something else.
And I believe that it is a result of culture.
And by culture, I mean gun culture in the
United States.
The idea that in the United States, more than
in so many other of the rich OECD countries
and the United States, there's this idea where
people see firearms as a solution to problems,
as a solution to interpersonal problems, as
a solution to being an NSL.
I mean, I know it sounds weird, but like that
that's also a factor in some of these shootings.
In individual cases, it's a solution to work
problems.
It's a solution to political problems in the
eyes of many, that is very different than
in other countries.
And so when you look at things like should
we have universal background checks?
Well, yeah, of course, when you look at the
2004 the federal assault weapons ban, which
expired in 2004, there were there was a spike
in shootings after that expired.
But there is a debate as to the degree to
which it is responsible, because there was
also the sort of furthering of this wacky
right wing gun culture at that point in time
during the era of George W. Bush.
And so it seems clear that there is a unique
set of circumstances in the United States,
which is culture, which includes ignorant
people.
It includes people who see guns as a solution
to problems, availability of guns.
Yes.
And then also, you know, lack of access to
mental health care and the fact that even
for people who do have access, it's often
highly stigmatized extremism.
There is a lot of extremism in the United
States compared to many other countries, which
leads people to look for things like guns
with which to then go and do things.
So my point here is not to say that it is
that that it is one issue at the exclusion
of others or that we shouldn't be looking
deeply at gun safety itself.
We absolutely should.
But we need to understand that there is also
something special in the United States.
A lot of these movements that in other countries
are hyper fringe, like hyper hyper fringe
in the United States, they are fringe, but
it's a big enough country where there's still
a lot of them.
60 Minutes segment over last weekend about
the Oath Keepers, which is one of these right
wing militia type groups.
These things exist.
I get it.
There's this right nationalist front in many
European countries.
And, you know, Australia has examples of these
groups.
Australia has very different gun laws, I think
it's important to say.
But there is a huge cultural component, which
if we ignore, we need to focus on the gun
piece because we're humiliatingly behind on
dealing with guns.
But there's also something special, and I
don't mean in a good way about American culture
that correlates and and I believe is causally
related to these shootings
as well.